amritsar in northern india its golden
temple is the holiest place for the sikh
religion now it's also known as a place
to buy drugs the spread of drug use has
brought with it hepatitis C psychologist
jôji pal singh bhatia runs a rehab
clinic in Amritsar many of his patients
are infected with the virus every second
person is hepatitis C every second
person infected heroin addicts share
syringes which spreads the disease more
and more young men are infected and the
situation has gotten worse in the past
few years I didn't see that much of
anything like that 10 years back 15
years back when they were and there
wasn't any IV use is directly related
with I we use and then it is transmitted
from husband to wife and then two kids
and then to the other people most of
those affected only find out about it
after visiting a rehab center like this
one good omen no people around me told
me that hepatitis C had no treatment so
I thought that I would die soon it's a
dangerously false assumption caused by a
lack of information hepatitis C can be
treated in India around 12 million
people have the virus according to world
health organization estimates in the
long term hepatitis C can lead to liver
problems like cirrhosis or even liver
cancer and if it's left untreated it can
indeed be fatal